hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
hi Kat Alvarado she's back for the 2018
year people hey Kat there's this thing
on Sunday called the Super Bowl what is
that it's where a bunch of grown men
throw around a ball and hit each other
really irrational why would men do that
I don't know it's something women would
do women do crazier things than men
all the time totally on the Super Bowl
they also drop a bunch of movie trailer
so I never watched the Super Bowl or go
to my friend's parties because I'm here
waiting for big trailers to drop alone
but I'll have John with me this year
yeah yeah well you know you get used to
being a man there's some Super Bowl
commercials out here and I heard some of
them are pretty great stuff and everyone
loves a good Super Bowl commercial
there's a lot of people watch so this
first one here
Alexa loses her voice Amazon Super Bowl
commercial Europe familiar with Alexa
right yes yes device and your home
that's my zone you for the cops and
Twitter
yeah show me a recipe for a grilled
cheese sandwich
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
from here okay I loved it it's good they
had a Lex's voice come back in the end
because I was like this is a weird Alexa
commercial there there Alexa the
machine's broken
someone just some famous person's voice
on there but it doesn't quite work is
the whole commercial was saying the
Alexa thing doesn't work but now it's
working yeah that's good you know what
all these commercials really have to do
is make us remember them and remember
the name and I think it accomplished
that oh yeah and you need famous people
in there too well three will make a
little game in it there's like four
there was one I didn't know when I
didn't know the rap one yeah I don't
know who that is I don't like rap it's
not my thing I only like country music I
wasn't a folk it's almost the same thing
you say folk you see the L oh well hey
there's more commercials you know it's
really a weird position here I'm like
off here you've got like the whole
Freddie okay it's my fault I read just
it you did or not you and I moved off to
the side too far yeah I don't want to
invade your space appreciate that
women's marches and freedoms it's
actually because you're scared your
girlfriend's gonna watch this and be
like why why see so close to this girl
what's your comfortable well I do fear
that it's an actual fear it's not
irrational anyway there's a Doritos one
here Oh
Doritos Blais versus Mountain Dew iced
Super Bowl commercial with Peter
Dinklage and Morgan Freeman you know
it's a game of Thrones reference blaze
and never mind cool range something hot
oh no I was I just like Game of Thrones
stops boys
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Spitfire
[Music]
see fire nice that's what is thing you
said blaze I he's blazing hi
well it says please write on yeah what's
making sense
I get what you mean now Fire and Ice oh
you know what I love about this
commercial
when serious actors behave like dummies
there's nothing better than watching two
serious people behave so goofy and I
appreciate that they took these songs
which are pretty outdated material right
now these are not current trending radio
songs but they threw it in there anyway
and we want to buy Doritos and mountain
dew now because Peter Dinklage and
Morgan Freeman said to buy it you know I
want to do more than that I want to
learn outdated rap songs and then link
them all right here we go my homeboy
Christopher Pratt he's so pretty he is
pretty he's your type he is he's exactly
my type did you train for this big role
make a little bulge of commercial
[Music]
[Music]
or what is your name like like they'd
have Chris Pratt audition no that's the
punch line at the end yeah that's funny
that's pretty funny
Chris Pratt man I love how his career
still flourishing during this divorce
but Anna Faris has her podcast and
whatever that she does she has a show
mom do people watch that there
I feel like moms who come home from work
watch that [ __ ] like my mom probably you
you know I know I don't watch it lady
who did my hair a year ago watch the
show I don't know if it's still on the
air and I think it is it's watched by
people like my dad and my stepmother
when they're like tired at the end of
the day they just from the TV on and
it's what's there
oh okay well Chris Pratt's in like
Marvel movies and Jurassic world and
Niccolo ultra Michelob Ultra now I know
what I'm gonna do for the Super Bowl
I'm going to buy Doritos buy some
Mountain Dew I want to mix my Mountain
Dew in the know and mix it with Michelob
Ultra
hello Ultra I think you did and we'll
have Alexa turn my TV on to the Super
Bowl Wow
the power of celebrity marketing has
really worked its way
in people Chris Pratt is beautiful he is
beautiful it's weird still seeing him
even though I'm used to seeing his body
in movies when I just seen out like guys
I always forget how ripped this guy is
like I don't even care that he's ripped
like I liked him before when he had a
little bit more meat on it used to be
really junky I would love to just like
rub that belly Wow
not like a big belly like a moderate
like eats pizza sometimes yeah so this
wasn't your type of body no I mean it's
fine like I wouldn't be like oh no
you're two reps sorry
never be me but I'm saying if a guy had
that face yeah a little bit more it's
fine Wow
well can we replay that commercial no
we're not we're not gonna do that I
could offer nerdy has Miri play anything
Chris Pratt
actually she hates Chris Pratt yeah she
likes the body types more like what you
described but more of like the dark she
doesn't really like white boys hence me
I don't look like a white boy I look
like an American actor who could play a
kid in Iraq well the Super Bowl is
coming up on Sunday people dedication
bell but do me a solid and follow the
Kat Alvarado on Instagram and Twitter
and Kat Alvarado comedy she posts photos
on the Instagram and she tweets about
Trump and how much she loves him and Kat
Alvarado comedy is all about how she
really felt that Hillary Clinton was
trying to rig the election 1000 billion
percent and then sometimes a tweet about
dating and like how I eat beets
we don't need the camera cup we don't
need to finish that Jeff it's okay his
Hawker video